welcome to this video playing the
national master this is a core hello
sequoia whatever I am still not able to
do to read this properly let them do the
bogo with 92 should I play a five or a
five I think if I've you can play I as
usual forgot all the stuff I have in the
book okay but it's a fairly Norman that
I should be able to play 98 and a five
ok now let's let's do some prep moves
first once a form yeah maybe I fall ok
like let's give us the queenside OE
actually takes I didn't expect that at
all okay but take with the pawn c5
probably see five okay it's not a big
deal i can i can play this the structure
here this isn't so bad
okay so night before is playing night if
five hmm ok yeah what I have six or
sisters this is a weird why should I do
that let's get the Queen out of the
default
I actually could have taken age 3 is
hanging at the end I never he's got
queen h 5 i'll show that later okay i
want to continue maybe even be 60 I not
to be six Bishop beside usually I put it
only six in this kind of structure but
this is not bad but should be seven it
puts some pressure on on before and the
night and often has a good post only six
anyway so
yeah don't know
oh is this position difficult on 95
should I go for some flavored yeah
justice i didn't expect but it's it's
it's quite good I cannot take what what
I cannot take hmm Wow then this is this
is a problem
okay I needed to do a five everything
else really it was completely completely
out wow did then I'm probably in very
very bad shape look Jake's wasn't really
sure
Jim it looks bad I don't see when yet
but maybe he does Quincy formed yeah
this this year but really I don't I
didn't really think this this would be
so great of course it's a pawn so it's
this much is clear but okay it takes
Queen shakes Jeff it wins I can't get
the rock on the FL the only chance get
something going here on the king not
that the king is too weak but this is
the only idea not g5f three this
actually would be something
don't to 20 something seconds grid
hmm
yeah what the heck if I spent ages and
didn't play well this combination is not
good Wow
check Jim
mob black forfeit this was really bad
yeah ah Oh f4 I really didn't didn't
appreciate that properly this is this is
terrible really terrible
yeah this still looks I know it looks
pretty okay I mean it's not the greatest
position ever but it should be you
should be playable and night before it's
the calm booth now that's also good what
can you say it's just good and logical
using this piece you have of course this
this whole idea is completely completely
just not working when I'm playing I was
always thinking okay I put this here
then maybe go for a 5 which is all nice
but he's his he's playing with f4 and
this is far too slow and now I have to
don't have a move I'm just lost here
he's threatening at five and dead cons I
have Nobles the best move according to
the comp is f six actually and this is
like like a disaster I can I can play
all a bit because it's fairly closed
yeah this is fairly stubborn even I mean
it's a crap position from black but it's
it's still something you can you can
continue to to defend yeah the this was
really a bad plan getting the night to
deform and with him playing a form of
course he played this nicely with 91
it's not difficult but it's strong
five maybe battalions it's crap it is
just a crap position now I need to play
it I need to really need to play this
night before after 92 and no a four is
good behind and I hear this one actually
this is of course another point and this
is actually playable yeah i saw this too
late this is the same in the game oops
here in the game man what was it you
know I could take and here he had
covered this phone no I cannot take
anymore I mean I can but it's it's not a
good move but I have a four for example
this is also probably better compared to
the game yeah i'm looking at this a bit
because this position is fairly standard
from this opening not like exactly this
position but the position type and I
always considered it to be m2 right okay
for black not spectacularly great but
like a playable position and it seems
okay White has got two bishops but the
bishop on g2 is not so great and black
black has a good bishop from structural
point of view and then not too bad
pieces yeah it should be a playable
position but I completely I chose the
wrong set up and he punish this nicely
thanks for watching